la rentrée c'était aujourd'hui pour les
parents l'heure est aussi à l'achat des
fournitures scolaires dans cette
enseigne spécialisée à montigny on se
prépare depuis quelques temps on ne peut
pas la liste scolaire se dire les
clients peuvent nous en vrai pas fax par
mail ou déposer une liste ici on ne peut
pas gratuitement il vient de payer comme
c'est le communisme tout le temps
c'est donc liste en main que les parents
font leurs courses les revenus les plus
faibles dispose d'une allocation de
rentrée pour les autres c'est un
véritable budget la rentrée se nouera
dépense plus les différentes affaires de
sport et autres qu'il faut renouveler
donc c'est un gros budget c'est encore
difficile
on cherche ce qui est sur la liste or
j'ai rarement les profs sont assez
précis et exigeant donc ma fille rentre
au collège c'est la première fois
qu'elle a une liste assez chargé donc
c'est la première fois que je fais une
rentrée dont j'avais pas vraiment le
budget maintenant je me rends compte de
ce que ça coûte bah oui j'en suis déjà à
plus de 100 euros oui
dans ce magasin on constate une
augmentation de 3 à 4% du nombre de
clients le rush est attendu pour le
week-end prochain